hello my name is not important
I represent the Ethics Committee seven
seals seven rings Seven Brides for the
Scarlet King the item that we're going
to be studying today is SCP 231 they
gather round the needle bed foolish and
the wise they fear the child yet to be
born whose voice shall render the skies
object class
Keter the faithful watch the forest for
the coming of King their lanterns bright
they wait at night for the new world he
shall bring sight and personal
requirements under special order of o
Thoth the following addendum is attached
to the beginning of the file for SCP 231
7 the dragon waits in shadows his breath
will scorch the land the hero in the
castle draws his sword makes his stand
all personnel assigned to SCP 231 7 must
rotate out for one month of
psychological counseling after two
months on site SCP 231 7 is to be kept
in an undisclosed location
all personnel assigned to NCP 231 will
be transported there blindfolded from
site 19 by a route including no fewer
than seven different forms of
transportation including but not limited
to aircraft automobile underground
tunnel and removal of blindfold during
the transport process is grounds for
immediate termination the princess in
the tower
it's hidden far away but nothing under
heaven can keep the groom at bay
personnel assigned to SCP 231 7 must
undergo heavy psychological testing
before being cleared to enter the site
individuals must score at least 72
points on the Milgram obedience
examination be unmarried have no
offspring and expressed nothing less
than total loyalty to the foundation
normal psychological screening
procedures against axis2 disorders are
waived so long as the Class D personnel
in question has the mental capacity to
carry out procedure 110-montauk as
needed personnel who expressed sympathy
towards SCP 231 sevens plight and/or
expressed a desire to rescue or
sympathise towards SCP 231 7 will be
transferred to another project without
delay any actual rescue attempts will be
met with immediate termination personnel
who have served on the staff of SCP 231
7 s containment team are not required to
divulge information to others no
official record shall be kept of the
names of any staff assigned to SCP 231 7
nor will said service appear in the
personnel files of said staff they
gather round with leering smiles while
on-site individuals assigned 231 7 will
be issued concealing helmets with
integrated voice changes to protect
their identity on-site staff are not to
remove said uniforms in the presence of
other staff members off-duty hours are
to be spent in private quarters alone 6
d-class personnel are to be assigned to
SCP 231 7 each month for the purposes of
carrying out procedure 110-montauk
violent criminals are not to be used for
this purpose due to the possibility of
accidental fatality during the
110-montauk process special containment
procedures following repeated escape and
suicide attempts and based on the
failure of containment for SCP 231 - one
through six containment of SCP 231 7 has
been amended to the following SCP 231 is
to be contained within a soundproof
holding cell
adjacent to holding cells for six Class
D personnel assigned for the purposes of
procedure 110-montauk cameras will
monitor every inch of the cell at all
times and must be manned 24 hours a day
malfunctioning monitoring equipment will
be replaced without delay by
psychologically screened staff doors
will be magnetically locked open herbal
only by positive action by the control
and monitoring facility this includes
all doors linking the main holding cell
to those of six Class D personnel SCP
231 seven is to be kept restrained to a
hospital bed at all times except for the
purposes of procedure 110-montauk
hydration will be provided through IV
drip feeding will be carried out twice a
day through feeding tube approved by
medical personnel who have not taken the
Hippocratic oath under no circumstances
are narcotics anesthesia or other
unapproved medications to be
administered to SCP 231 seven the Potter
told his Prentice to prepare him seven
jars six he made with grace and skill
procedure 110-montauk is to be carried
out at least once every 24 hours by
Class D personnel during procedure
110-montauk at least one security
clearance for 231 staff member must
monitor the procedure by camera at all
times although the sound may be turned
off if the vocalizations of SCP 231
seven become too distressing following
the procedure all Class D personnel must
return to their holding cells or
explosive collars will be detonated the
curtain move no more
gone it's morning black in their dreams
it's faces proudly
come to take them back they punched more
durable I've redacted on remarketed
information moved to my loan document -
31 - 110-montauk - 110-montauk is
limited to personnel with security
clearance for / - 31 description SCP -
31-7 is a female between 10 years of age
with the king is in this courting close
the brides are in their beds the unborn
Prince's waiting sleep to raise their
eager heads ICP - 31 - 1 through 7 were
retrieved from following a police raid
on a warehouse owned by an organization
called the children of the Scarlet King
see article in the newspaper police raid
satanic sex cult save 7 24 hours after
the rescue SCP - 31 one real neck went
into labor pains giving birth three
minutes later - SCP causing a event
resulting up and confirmed casualties
foundation personnel immediately took
possession of remaining scps - 31 -
through - - 31 7 and based on notebooks
recovered from the cult instituted
procedure 110-montauk to prevent future
occurrences the hens were in the
henhouse and 7 eggs did lay til Fox
crept in
of night and stole the eggs away
addendum 231 a current status of SCP 231
units six we're broken by their bindings
six no more shall sing comes the seventh
full unwinding and all the bells will
ring SCP 231 one deceased s-- killed
during initial recovery operations while
giving birth to SCP c casualty report
for event 231 alpha for more details
when the first had given birth and all
the birds did sing a screaming cries did
shake the skies
she called out for her SCP 231 two
deceased killed during attempt to remove
fetus of second SCP specimen resulting
in immediate thank c casualty report for
event two three one brother for more
details my doctors blade the second bay
and life into the world entirely human
either silent moon the kings red flag on
for SE p 231 three deceased self
terminated following a prolonged period
of distress caused by implementation of
procedure 110-montauk as he immediately
underwent a command c casualty report
for event 231 charlie for more details
his bride the third remained unheard her
cries for help ignored she stopped her
life with a surgeon's knife and gave it
to SCP 231 for deceased attempted to
administer scp-500 although successful
in that all traces of SCP were expelled
from the system expelled remains
immediately underwent event
causing numerous casualties including a
CP 231 for herself see casualty report
for event to that he want Delta for more
details the 4th prepares a dagger and
places it at her heart the perfect cure
cannot make pure the King SCP 231 five
deceased botched application of
procedure 110-montauk resulted in SCP
231 five giving birth to a CP one hour
later which then underwent event C
casualty report for event 231 echo and
report on destruction of site 231 Aleph
for more details
recruitment profile of Class D personnel
was revised to minimize possibility of a
second botched procedure 110-montauk v
ones crowd was bearing down on the fox's
said SCP 231 six deceased killed during
escape attempt aided and abetted by
agent who had been exhibiting heightened
stress levels due to prolonged exposure
to a CP 231 obtained possession of SCP
and attempted to you said weapon to
rescue SCP 231 6 and 231 7 agent was
killed in the resulting fire fight but a
stray round resulted in the termination
of SCP 231 6 as well the fetus of SCP
231 6 is SCP then underwent vent in the
wake of this incident oh five personnel
voted by unanimous decision to amend
personnel policies see casualty report
for event 2 3 1 Foxtrot for more details
on the sixth day the walls gave way and
the oceans turned to harsh
earth gave walk as the earth shook
underneath the Kings fell - SCP 231 7 as
of SCP 231 7 is successfully contained
at site 7th bride will break the tides
to move no more will shine there comes a
day not far away she addendum 231 B this
is a recording of a missive by o5 dear
friends it has come to my attention that
recently certain rumors have surfaced
regarding a CP 231 due to a drop in
staff her out I've decided to address
some of the more prevalent points yes
procedure 110-montauk is as horrible as
you've heard which is why only Class D
personnel are authorized to carry it out
yes it does involve brutal no assignment
to SCP 231 is not intended to test your
loyalty to the foundation your
tendencies towards or anything else no
SCP 231 is not punishment detail yes
there are staff members who have been on
SCP 231 and have successfully
transferred out by their own request no
not everyone who's worked on a CP 231 is
terminated upon leaving the project yes
staff members who have been assigned to
SCP 231 are allowed to take class am
musics before leaving the project if so
desire yes false memories are then
implanted no none of the supposed
methods for recovering or detecting
false memories work yes there are some
of you who worked on SCP 231 and don't
remember it
no we have not given up trying to save
SCP 231 - 7 but research in that field
must be carried out with the utmost of
caution based on the increased potency
of each subsequent event associated with
each subsequent SCP specimen there is a
strong possibility then SCP 231 - 7
could result in a hack skate class end
of the world scenario this information
is corroborated and notebooks recovered
from the cultists see documents seven
Brian's seven seals
and CP 231 adjunct B no putting the girl
out of her misery is not an option
neither is drugging her she has to be
aware of what is going on for
110-montauk to work one final note the
foundation does many distasteful things
in the completion of our mission but our
mission is important enough that the
price is one we must pay containment of
SCP 231 is one of our most dangerous
duties not because of any direct danger
to ourselves but because of the danger
that our resolve will fail that we will
let ourselves to either let down our
guard due to our sympathy for the
suffering of an innocent or that we will
allow ourselves to become monsters
through the performance of monstrous
acts just do your jobs and save the
philosophizing for the shrink your
sincerely Oh fight
addendum 231 C update 231 sevens
emotional response to procedure
110-montauk appears to be reduced
recently
despite proper execution of said
procedure increasing danger of SCP
undergoing event two options have been
proposed number one development of a new
containment procedure with higher
emotional response than procedure
110-montauk number two administration of
a Class A amnestics to SCP 231 7
allowing for a return to base emotional
response state said memory modification
is to be administered during execution
of procedure 110-montauk to maintain
heightened emotional state following
memory reset please advise the doctor
never tells his god which one he really
seeks instead he hides himself away and
quietly he beeps doctor addendum 231 D
decision carry out option 2 at the first
available opportunity there God's own
voice he makes the choice declaring the
word in fear and pain o 5 addendum 231 e
aftermath option 2 was carried out SCP
231 7's emotional state returned to a
hundred percent efficacy doctor
subsequently committed suicide due to
heightened emotional stress will
continue analysis of efficacy of
treatment
the doctors gum ended his run as he put
it to his ear as she was defiled the
pitied child he gave it to his fear
doctor addendum 231 F continued analysis
of efficacy of treatment after some
analysis I've determined that it is not
necessary to perform memory modification
every time procedure 110-montauk is
carried out in fact it is better to
delay for some time before re
administering the agent analysis of
subject 231 sevens emotional response
indicates that efficacy of procedure
110-montauk seems to peak between the
third and fourth performance of the
procedure the dread of anticipation
before the event seems to heighten
emotional response for a time before
familiarity with the procedure begins to
lessen the efficacy of the treatment my
recommendation is that class-a amnestics
be administered once a week during
procedure 110-montauk the calendar has
been modified accordingly her memory a
fickle thing the strongest shall endure
when her weeping starts to waver the
drugs doctor
thank you very much for your attention
you are dismissed
you